[Musik]
hallo herr zu sallys welt heute möchte
ich euch zeigen wie vielfältig pesto
sein kann
ihr könnt zum einen natürlich pesto
selber machen da gibt es auch schon ein
rezept auf meinem blog oder wenn ihr
sagt ich habe jetzt gar keine zeit oder
ich habe auch kein frisches basilikum
auf der terrasse im garten oder hinten
in der küche dann können wir natürlich
auch auf pastor zurückgreifen wenn ich
fest und nehme dann immer gerne von
barilla weiß wirklich auch mit echtem
publikum gemacht ist und zuversicht zu
kochen und das können wir dadurch nicht
nur verwenden um zum beispiel nudeln
zuzubereiten sondern heute zeige ich
euch fünf verschiedene varianten mit
pesto fangen wir jetzt zuerst einmal an
mit dem pesto zu früh
für den teig verwende ich einen halben
würfel hefe einen esslöffel zucker einen
teelöffel salz 3 150 milliliter wasser
500 gramm mehl vier esslöffel olivenöl
und natürlich mein pesto ich nehme jetzt
zuerst einmal die hefe die kommt direkt
in eine schüssel gemeinsam mit dem
zucker und dem wasser jetzt kann ich die
hefe darin auflösen
das ist super schnell zuzubereiten das
heißt ihr könnt den entweder mit der
hand verkneten mit der küchenmaschine
oder mit einem handrührgerät die werte
kurz auflösen
da gebe ich jetzt mail dazu erstmal nur
ein und teil gebe ich das salz dazu und
kann das ganze jetzt schon mal verkneten
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt auch das olivenöl
betreiben und dann nach und nach das
restliche mehl
[Musik]
die habe ich einen schönen geschmeidigen
zeigt er auch wirklich schön weich ist
und kann den nicht abdecken und dann für
etwa zwei stunden aufgehen lassen
jetzt ist der hefeteig schön aufgegangen
und guck mal zu mir jetzt beelen wir
unsere arbeitsfläche lange wartet beim
brotbacken helfen noch ein bisschen
jetzt kommt der weichen teig jetzt kommt
hier noch ein bisschen mehl obendrauf
ein bisschen wackelig
jetzt sollte dem teig aus zu einem
großen rechteck
wenn man die teigplatten und jetzt kommt
hier direkt das pesto drauf und pesto
gibt sie in verschiedenen ausführungen
zum beispiel rotes pesto oder wie hier
pesto genovese basilikum
[Musik]
zurzeit platte schneiden wir jetzt in
streifen
und ich nehme jetzt hier diese bank form
also eine kuchen backform die fertig
jetzt mit back trance break ihr könnt
aber auch eine eckige backform verwenden
oder wie sanierer sag mal deine ein
bärchen aber ein bisschen einfetten auf
jeden fall jetzt nehmen wir den teig und
legen den wie eine ziehharmonika
entfalten
ganz vorsichtig und jetzt hoch nehmen
und so
[Musik]
und während sanierer noch waltet kann
ich das schon mal hier in die backform
reinlegen
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr den teig entweder
abdecken und noch mal eine halbe stunde
aufgehen lassen oder einfach direkt in
den kalten backofen schieben so mache
ich das jetzt so kommt jetzt bei mir in
den kalten backofen dann stelle ich
ihnen auf etwa 190 grad und lass ihn
packen
wer möchte kann dann noch dampf stoß
dazu geben so wird despoten bisschen
flüssiger wie sehr mir jetzt sagen würde
und knuspriger von außen oder einfach
ohne dampf stoßen nach dem backen lässt
sich das protein ganz kurz abkühlen und
stürzte es auch direkt schon aus der
backform heraus dass brot muss auch gar
nicht geschnitten werden sondern jeder
kann sich einfach kleines stückchen
abreisen oder abzuziehen
[Musik]
mit pastor können die auch ganz einfach
tipps zu bereiten ich nehme jetzt hier
für das pesto etwas frisch käse und
joghurt dann hat man einen schönen
leichten tipp und das kann man zum
beispiel dann für gemüse sticks oder
auch kristin i also brot sticks
verwenden oder zum beispiel auch als
beilage zum grillen also also so zum
dippen dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach den
frischkäse
da kommt ihnen eine rührschüssel und da
könnt ihr entweder die deutschen raum
stufe oder sogar die leichtere version
mit joghurt verwenden dann etwas joghurt
dann nehme ich immer gerne naturjoghurt
und da kommt jetzt einfach noch pastor
dazu
[Musik]
jetzt werden die zutaten einfach mit
einem schneebesen kurz glatt gerührt
anschließend könnt ihr die dips dann in
verschiedene gläser einfüllen und dann
gemüse sticks oder zb eintauchen und
probieren
mit meiner freundin zusammen bereits mit
total gerne slum kochen so die hat
nämlich in flammkuchen ofen bei sich im
garten und dann gibt es im prinzip immer
ungefähr 20 verschiedene flammkuchen
ich habe letztes mal dann pastor
mitgebracht und wir haben mit pastor den
flammkuchen aufgepimpt im prinzip könnt
ihr da jetzt entweder den klassischen
flammkuchen machen mit speck und
zwiebeln oder so wie ich eine ganz
andere variation für den flammkuchen
verwende ich nämlich gerne flammkuchen
teig entweder selbst gemacht oder fett
gekauft dann natürlich etwas schmand
hier habe ich jetzt hähnchenbrust dies
bereits geräuchert frühlingszwiebeln
tomaten testo salz und pfeffer nehmt ihr
natürlich zuerst einmal spannend den
habe ich bereits gewürgt einfach mit ein
bisschen salz und pfeffer immer frisch
gemahlen aus der mühle
doch kurz verhören und zur seite legen
und dann kann ich auch schon die
frühlingszwiebeln in ringe schneiden
tomaten nämlich und halbiere sehen
und die hähnchenbrust wird dann noch in
streifen geschnitten
jetzt ist auch schon alles vorbereitet
ist kann ich den flammkuchen teilnehmen
und mit dem stand besprechen
[Musik]
und das beste kommt jetzt einfach in
töpfen oben drauf wenn ihr möchtet
könnte es aber auch direkt mit der crème
fraiche oder dem stand auch schon
verrühren
aber sie ist immer ein bisschen schülern
[Musik]
und jetzt mit eurem lieblingszutaten
belegen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich zwar keine flammkuchen
ofen aber im backofen werden die
flammkuchen auch super knusprig
[Musik]
flammkuchen ist fertig ist das lecker
guckt mal schön knusprig
und das ist so schnell gemacht und ist
einfach nur super lecker
wollt ihr auch probieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im sommer esse ich gerne mal was
leichtes und salat auf jeden fall dazu
ich werde jetzt eine salat zubereiten
mit gebackener hähnchenbrust dafür
nehmen sie an ihnen fehle und die werden
in der pfanne zubereitet mit pesto
verfeinert dazu gibt es den leckeren
salat für die gebratene hähnchenbrust
verwende ich ps lottelo olivenöl für
hähnchenbrustfilets etwas pesto und für
den salat nehme ich jetzt einfach bunte
paprika tomaten eine zwiebel meinen
joghurt stressen und etwas salat ich ja
jetzt setzt zuerst aus olivenöl in einer
pfanne und bin ich der native olivenöl
verwendet dann darf man es auch erhitzen
und damit braten
jetzt kann die wm frust von beiden
seiten angebraten werden
[Musik]
und ich kann jetzt in der zwischenzeit
schon mal den salat zubereiten
über den salat gebe es jetzt meinen
joghurt dressing und das findet ihr
bereits ganz viele das salatdressing 6
uhr auf meinem normalen bei joghurt
passt hervorragend
der schmeckt dann einfach schön leicht
das ist irrsinn brustdurchschuss sie von
beiden seiten etwas zwei minuten
angebraten und jetzt gebe ich noch das
best oder so und es gibt da hin zum
großen wirklich toll und witzigen
geschmack
das habe ich hier in legden knackigen
salat und da jetzt schön dass
hähnchenbrustfilet das riecht auch schon
richtig toll und wird sich
[Musik]
und so könnt ihr wirklich ganz schnell
und vor allem ziemlich einfach ein
abendessen zubereiten was nicht so
lecker schmeckt sondern auch super
aussieht
und wenn ihr jetzt sagt okay ich bin
nicht so der salat typ wie moora zum
beispiel da bin ich der typ dazu
dann habe ich jetzt noch die nächste
idee für euch denn wir machen noch eine
leckere sandwich toaster
[Musik]
für diesen test verwende ich
vollkorntoast brotscheiben ich nehme
tomaten mozzarella und pesto und im
prinzip geht es jetzt auch ziemlich
einfach geht auch morgens ganz schnell
mal fürs frühstück oder auch einfach so
als zwischen snack der mozzarella wird
jetzt einfach in scheiben geschnitten
genauso wie die tomaten
[Musik]
jetzt das brot oben und unten mit
historisch halte also auf den
innenseiten
und jetzt mit tomaten mozzarella belegen
[Musik]
zu klappen und ich habe immer gerne
mozzarella oben also einmal umdrehen
dann von außen mit etwas olivenöl
bestreichen so wird die kruste auch
richtig schön man kann das aber auch
weglassen
und jetzt nur noch draußen muratow das
gleich zum probieren kommen schon fertig
[Musik]
damit so ein bisschen frischer wert
mache ich es noch mal kurz auf war dass
ich mal ganz lecker wie sich auch
morgens schnell gemacht hätten wenn wir
was zu frühstücken also positiv und hat
es auch wieder zu hause und guck mal
noch ein bisschen rucola rein den magst
du mich ziemlich cool das ganze ding pro
jahr das sind vitamine und ich finde es
auch nochmal richtig frisch aus dreieck
oder rechte dreieck finde ich cool und
[Musik]
guck mal
für dich mit liebe gemacht aber hier
obst runter gelaufen aber das ist okay
es ist richtig gespräche zu probieren
[Musik]
genial oder so kann man ganz einfach
auch den toast ein bisschen auskennt und
einfach ein bisschen mehr würze
reinbringen und die ideen waren ziemlich
cool also fünf geniale ideen mit pesto
wirklich einmal das brot das war schon
sehr gut für den grill oder zum beispiel
einfach als beilage sondern hauptgericht
dann hatten wir die gemüsesticks mit
nörgelnden gibt das war auch ziemlich
genial
der salat war mein absolutes highlight
mit der hinten post im pesto und mein
highlight war der bug in der aula und
kuchen für petrus das ist einfach etwas
was man zwischendurch oder auch mal
morgens essen kann
ich hoffe ich konnte euch inspirieren
und vielleicht macht er das eine oder
andere rezept man nach wenn datum
verlinkt mich auf jeden fall mit diesem
herr steckt und sehen wir auch eure
genialen rezepte vielleicht habe es aber
auch ihr weitere ideen mit pesto dann
lasst mich wissen dann mache ich gerne
noch ein weiteres video dazu also viel
spaß beim nachmachen guten appetit und
wieder bis zum nächsten mal
es war schwierig dinge probiert ein
pesto mozzarella perfekte kombi
[Musik]